so I want to be talking about full stack
development with the grand stack which
is graph QL react Apollo in unity
database so my name's will I work at
near forge a which is an open source
graph database I don't work on the the
core engineering team for near 4j
instead the the team I work on builds
integrations so making sure that you can
use neo4j with your favorite web
development framework that you can move
data back and forth from different data
processing frameworks tools like that
and so what I'm going to talk about
today is largely the the most recent
integration that that I've been working
on which is a near forge a graph QL
integration which makes up a big part of
the of the grand stack but if you get
bored while while I'm talking you can go
to bit dot Lee slash graph hacker and
there's a little challenge there
basically it will take you to an Apollo
launch pad which is a tool for building
a graph QL service in the browser and
there's just a couple of steps to follow
basically just connect connect that
launch pad to a hosted near for J
instance and get the graph QL service
working and then just tweet us about it
and we'll send you one of these cool you
everyday graphic QL hacker t-shirts you
don't have to do it while I'm talking
you can can do it later too cool so uh
so what do I want to talk about well I
want to talk about this this idea of the
grand stack so these these technologies
that we can use together to build to
build full stack applications because
most of most of our developers I want to
talk about focus on the how we do this
so we're gonna go through go through
some code samples of how we can build a
full stack grand stack application but
first of all what what is the the grand
stack what are these components so the
first component of the grand stack is
graph QL how many people have used graph
QL
at all okay cool so that's maybe like a
call that like two-thirds of the
audience so graph QL is this new
paradigm for building API is it's an
alternative for building REST API is
it's very focused around a schema
definition so we start by defining a
schema we define the types that are
available the fields available on these
types and then we can select from the
schema on the client which fields we
want in our query the other components
are say the next component is reacts how
many people use react okay that's that's
a lot of folks cool so as you all know
react is this this JavaScript library
for building user interfaces for web
native VR very much focused on on
components that encapsulate data and
logic and then we have Apollo how many
people have used any of the Apollo
tooling a few folks yes so Apollo is not
just a single tool Apollo is instead a
suite of tools for working with graph QL
so you see Apollo show up both on on the
client side with things like Apollo
client and then also on server side
tooling for building and graph QL
service things like performance
monitoring and mocking so when we say
Apollo in this example today we're going
to look at the Apollo clients
specifically the react integration for
Apollo client but really there are lots
of different Apollo projects that help
with we're going to graph QL throughout
the throughout the stack and then the
final components is an irritant database
how many people have used neo4j okay
okay a few so near 4j is is a native
graph database what that means is that
we use the property graph to store model
and queried
as a graph so nodes are the entities in
the in the graph relationships connect
them we can store arbitrary key value
pair of properties on nodes and
relationships we use the the cipher
query language for working with data in
neo4j
you can see a an example at the bottom
of the screen there and then we have
client drivers in lots of different
languages for working with me or for J's
so in the example today we will be using
the JavaScript driver for near forge a
cool so those are the individual
components of the grand stack how do
they how do they fit together
well let's look at a simple example
let's consider a super simple movie
search and recommendation web app so
what are the the requirements for this
well user should be able to search by
title and then view some movie details
for any matching movies and then we also
want to show personalized
recommendations so for for this movie
that a user searched for what are some
other movies that user might like and if
you're familiar with graph databases
this kind of recommendation query is
really easy to express in a graph so if
you've if you use Amazon or e-commerce
things people who bought this also
bought this for movies
someone who viewed and rated this movie
highly also rated these other movies
highly that that's a simple example we
can do much more complex things but
that's the general idea okay so with
that sort of that application in mind
how do the the piece of the grand stack
fit together well we have react on the
front end the user types in their movie
river runs through it hits search and
the Apollo client integration in this
case sends a graph QL query to our graph
QL service our graph QL server has logic
in there to query our neo4j database to
look up movies by
idle and that data comes back to Apollo
client the react integration for Apollo
client binds the graph QL query results
to the props for our view for our
components and in the view is rendered
okay so that's that's how those pieces
fit together let's look at that in a bit
more detail starting starting at the
data layer so starting with with neo4j
so since since I everyone is familiar
with me here for J I want to spend just
a little bit of time talking about what
is near for J and I think the best way
to explain something is often in the
form of a tweet
so here's near for J in 140 characters I
guess I could redo this in 280 now so
near for J is open source software that
stores inquiries data as nodes and
relationships using the cipher query
language with index free adjacency okay
so there's there's a bit going on there
let's dissect that a bit so first of all
in here for J is open source software
all the code is on github we can we can
go build it from source we can we can
download it we can use the docker image
for neo4j so lots of different ways to
get near 4j never do is primarily a
database so focused on modeling storing
and querying data so when we we write
some data tenir for j it's durably
committed to disk near for j is not just
an in-memory processing framework it's
it's very much a database okay so it
allows us to store in query data as
nodes and relationships so we said that
nodes these are the entities or the
objects in the graph and relationships
connect them so relationships are
first-class citizens in the data model
and we can store key value pairs so
properties attributes both on nodes and
relationships and if you look at this
this data model this might look somewhat
familiar if you've been following the
news recently so this is the data model
from the Paradise Papers data leak so
this was leaked data from in this case a
law firm in the Bahamas that had lots of
information on rich people that had
connections to offshore legal entities
and the the data journalists that were
working with this leaked data they use
near 4j to make sense of the connections
to these offshore legal entities and and
this makes sense if you think of a
person who has some shareholder interest
in a legal entity that is the
beneficiary of another legal entity that
is a shareholder in an offshore trust
and things like this where there's a
very long path to get to the ultimate
beneficial owner so that kind of data
makes a lot of sense to work with in a
graph so we we model store and query the
data as nodes and relationships using
the cipher query language so here's a
cipher example and this this again this
is querying the the Paradise Papers data
set so this is saying find addresses in
London find all of the officers so in
this case the people find all of the
people with addresses in London and then
for those people find all of the legal
entities that they're connected to so
you can see that cipher is very much
about pattern matching in that first
line in the match statement we're
defining a graph pattern so we define
nodes within parenthesis relationships
within brackets and we're basically
traversing the graph to find paths that
match this pattern of people with
addresses in London and their
connections to offshore entities and if
we run this in your browser we get this
graph visualization okay so these are
all the people with addresses in London
that have connections to offshore legal
entities from the paradise papers and
this is useful to sort of see where
there are some high
connected clusters we can see a couple
of connected clusters there there's
something something interesting going on
there someone that has lots of
connections to legal entities okay
that's interesting
but often times the answer to our
question is not a graphical ization
maybe it's the result of of an
aggregation or maybe it's tabular data
so we can modify our query slightly to
ask a different question in this case
we're saying okay for all these people
with addresses in London that have some
connection to offshore legal entities
what are the most common jurisdictions
for those offshore legal entities so for
people in London where do they like to
hide their money offshore
well Bermuda is the most common offshore
jurisdiction followed by the Cayman
Islands Mauritius is on the list as well
so the point there is just that graph
queries are not just about graph
utilizations we can do sort of the same
things that you would expect from other
query languages like sequel and that
kind of thing so first part of the open
cipher project so it's an open call and
whadja is implemented by other databases
other processing frameworks we can use
cipher with spark for example okay so
back to our tweet so neo4j open source
software stores and queries data as
nodes relationships using cipher with
index free adjacency so this last part
index free adjacency is an important
performance characteristic of graph
databases what this means is that when
we Traverse from one node to any other
through a relationship that we're
connected to we're not doing an index
lookup that means that the performance
then of a local graph traversal is a
constant time operation it's not
dependent on the overall size of the
data so our query is on a data set of
you know a few million nodes then can
scale to one with several billion nodes
so we can scale these queries to very
very large data sets this is a really
important performance characteristic of
graphic
it's very different from other types of
databases okay so that was my near for J
and 140 characters overview if you're
interested in playing around with you
for J or that paradise paper is data set
as well new everyday sandbox is a good a
good example of a way to spin up near 4j
incidents with some different datasets
they're hosted on AWS with some example
queries you can can play around and get
started okay so let's take a look at at
some data in near for J since we we said
we want to build out our movie
recommendation app and I said we were
gonna look at data about movies and and
user ratings but but I lied instead
let's look at some data about Russian
Twitter trolls so so again if you've
been following the the news at least
this has been been big in the US I think
in Europe too but there's been
investigation into Russia's meddling
with the US election especially through
social media and so twitter twitter
released a list of 3000 screen names
that are tied to russia and then
promptly suspended those accounts which
deleted all of the tweets from Twitter
calm and from the Twitter API so can't
really figure out what those 3,000
Russian trolls were tweeting about but I
I found some of them on Internet Archive
so I scraped Internet Archive for all
the tweets I could find by these Russian
trolls and put them in near for J so
here's the here's the schema that we
have so we have we have a tweet a tweet
was posted by a user so user posted two
tweets then we have hashtags
we have URLs that the tweet might
contain oh and then I also ran some some
simple natural language processing
like Kennedy extraction to find any any
people organization or locations that
any of these tweets mentioned so let's
look at look at an example query so for
one user this is ten underscore GOP so
this was an account that was intended to
look like a political party of the state
of Tennessee in the US but was very much
not so we can say okay show me all of
the tweets posted by this user and have
a hashtag and show me all of the the
hashtags for these tweets and we can get
back sort of this sort of visualization
so here's the user it's posted post some
tweets so here's something about civil
rights that Trump is taking away we can
see some of the the hashtags that are
used we can see here that here's several
tweets from this user that that use the
hashtag Barcelona so we can sort of get
an idea of what what this account was
was tweeting about and we can we can run
queries over the the full date data set
so this one is interesting what are what
are the most common hashtags that are
used and for some reason that there's a
lot of a lot of tweets that we captured
in German targeting I think things going
around around miracles reelection in
Germany we can also look at the hashtags
used together most frequently which i
think is also interesting and again we
get a lot of a lot of German tweets
there okay so that's the that's the data
set that I actually want to work with
instead of instead of movies so keep
that that data set in mind and we'll
talk about how to build a graph QL
service on top of this so so first of
all let's talk a little bit about about
graph QL so he said the graphic you
is this new paradigm for building API is
it's not really a query language for a
database necessarily but instead it's a
query language for API so it's a way of
specifying data and then querying the
data but it's limited support for what
we would think of as queries like
there's no support for aggregations or
filtering things like that and then
there's also a big community of tools
built around graphic UL so graphical
which we'll look at in a second is this
sort of in browser IDE for working
working with graphic you well we already
mentioned mocking and performance so the
the schema is really important in graph
QL it defines what data is available and
then a client for any given requests
selects only the data that that the
client is interested in from the schema
and this reduces then the amount of data
that Scents sent over the wire and it
also allows the client to pick the data
it needs to render a particular view and
these were the the two reasons that that
Facebook created graph QL originally it
was to be able to render a view with a
single round-trip request and to reduce
the data sense sent over the wire so
this was particularly Facebook's native
apps over slow networks where this sort
of network latency is really obvious
when you have multiple requests to
render a view graph QL also makes this
this observation that your application
data is a graph and we'll come back to
this in a minute because this thing this
is pretty important so here's a graph QL
query we're looking up a business by ID
and then we're specifying some fields
that we that we want to grab okay so
what's the the graph piece of this well
graph QL makes this observation that
your application data is a graph sort of
irrespective of how we store that on the
back ends but when we're talking about
our
Gatien data in the clients that puts a
graph and we're traversing it with
graphically well so we're starting from
the business within seeing okay what are
the the categories connected to this
business okay for those category objects
what are the the name property
associated with that and so on so we're
traversing traversing this graph and we
get back get back our results notice
that the the shape of our result matches
matches our query because those are the
fields that we specified that we're
interested in so this this observation
that your application data is a graph is
interesting because it implies then that
if you're not using a graph database on
the backend if we're using a relational
database or a document database then
there's some sort of mapping and
translation that has to occur from our
application data graph graph QL to how
we're storing and modeling that data in
the backend let's take a look at
graphical so we can sort of see our data
being queried live so here's graphical
this is sort of this this in browser IDE
for working with graph QL and this is
querying the the neo4j database that I
have running so let's just grab the
first three tweets or requiring for
hashtag politics finding the first three
tweets grabbing the text but we can also
see all the other hashtags in the tweet
and and so on so you can see how our
response is changing as we're adding
adding more fields here let's skip some
of these slides and talk about how we
build a graphical service so so the
first thing we do is define a schema and
then we define resolver functions that
define how we fetch data for that schema
here's our movie schema but let's take a
look at
our Russian Twitter troll schema looks
like this so we have it's pretty simple
we have three types we have tweets we
have a user we have a hashtag and we
also have a link and you can see the
fields that are available so we have so
a tweet has has a text it has a
permalink and our fields can reference
other types so a tweet has an author
that's that's a user here and then the
other important thing that we define in
our graph QL schema is the entry point
for our graphic ul service so here we
have two entry points so these are the
the queries the graphical queries that
we can run we can start by looking up
hash tags by by tag or we can do tweets
by text so search the text of tweets to
find tweets and we define we define our
schema using this schema definition
language which is this sort of language
agnostic way of defining a schema okay
and then we said our resolver function
has the logic for fetching fetching that
data so this is what a typical resolver
function looks like where for our entry
point we define how in this case a
cipher query to look up a movie by title
but then we have some other fields that
that's not resolving so things like our
recommended movies so we have to have
another query to find our recommended
movies our genres are in another another
node so we need to have another query to
find our John Rah's so if we end up with
a non-trivial
graph QL query what we end up with are
lots of these different queries that are
multiple round trips to the database so
we end up having to batch these for
performance and this is typical for for
really any graph QL implementation so
what we wanted to look at where as well
could we build a new fridge a graphic UL
integration that offers some some
developer productivity benefits really
implementing those resolvers seems kind
of tedious we're
just sort of writing cipher queries
there and if we do this with a
relational abit database for writing
sequel or we're writing our ORM queries
so is there a way that we could
translate graph QL to cipher and then
not have to write those resolver
functions and then would this give us
better performance because we can just
generate a single cipher query so that's
one round-trip to the database rather
than having to batch a bunch of queries
and then could we expose cipher through
graph QL because have graph QL is
somewhat limited and support for
projections aggregations so these are
the things we wanted to wanted to
explore and so we built what we call
near photographed qlj s which is a
integration for graph QL linear for J
that basically takes the graph QL schema
and uses this to drive what the neo4j
data model should be which then allows
us to translate arbitrary cipher queries
- I'm sorry arbitrary graph QL queries -
cipher and what this means is that for
any any given graph QL query there is
just a single cipher query so a single
round-trip to the database in here for J
has a very smart cipher execution engine
so those end up being being optimized
pretty well and then we can also expose
cipher in graph QL with a cipher
directive so in our schema definition we
can annotate any of these fields so this
is a this is a field called similar on
on our movie type so we said we needed
to generate movie recommendations for a
movie
so this fields similar in this case
we're just looking for movies that have
the same genre but we could have a much
more complex query there looking at user
ratings or something like that and that
done becomes a computed field so that's
this idea of the the cipher schema
directive
and that still is just one cipher query
that we are able to generate that
computed field essentially becomes a sub
query in our cipher query okay so we
thought we thought that was was pretty
good and if we if we take a look here
[Music]
this so this is the graph QL server
implementation that I was hitting when I
was running graphical here so my my
Russian Twitter data and this is the
only code to to implement my resolver so
I don't I don't have to write any cipher
there basically all I'm doing is calling
the New York geographic Q L integration
passing along the graph QL query and any
parameters and our integration is
generating the cipher behind-the-scenes
these are these are the generated
queries so here you can see we were
looking for the hashtag politics and
looking for any tweets that have that
hashtag and and so on
so anyway so so I think this was really
cool this was a big a big I think
developer productivity boost it allows
you also still to have the flexibility
of querying other services so if you
want to fetch data from another another
database you can do that as well just
implement your own resolve or rather
than calling out to the to the
integration cool so that's that's the
near video graph QL integration I'm
about out of time so I'm gonna gonna
skip over this this react piece I think
we're all pretty familiar with react the
only thing I want to say about about the
react Apollo integration is that Apollo
clients the react integration for Apollo
client is really neat because it allows
us to basically bind a components props
to a graphic UL query that's sort of the
the only missing piece here and my my
super simple react app that I wrote
in just a few minutes as you can see
with no no styling or anything basically
this allows us to search by by hashtag
so all it's doing is binding our tweet
list
props to to a graphic Gale crane
anyway the code is is online if anyone
wants to check that out I just want to
mention a couple of things one is that
these sorts of integrations that we're
building these are largely feedback
driven so this if this sounds like an
interesting project like something that
you might want to play around with
please do and then let us know what you
think are there features that would be
helpful
a lot of snow we can build them it's
really our goal is to sort of figure out
what's sort of the sort of integrations
like this make sense to make it easier
to build to build cool applications so
I'll mention just just a couple of
resources at the New York J's sandbox
which I mentioned before is a great way
to get started with New Year forge a it
has this data set for movies and movie
recommendations that power the the movie
app that I didn't really talk about but
as other other data sets as well that
are really fun and this portal grand
stack I oh this is sort of a landing
page that collects
lots of information about these
integrations that we're working on has
documentation and tutorials for these
different different projects so if you
want to get started looking at looking
at grand stack apps or any of these
integrations that I talked about that's
a good place to to start cool so that
that is what I have to say yeah question
yeah yes so the question is there's this
other database called DeGraff why would
I why would I use neo and instead of D
graph for a graph QL integration so so D
graph is is a triple store it it's not
quite the same thing as a graph
database but for intents and purposes is
very similar they they use something
kind of like graph QL for their query
language they call it graph QL plus - I
think so they they sort of have added
some things too to their flavor of graph
QL and like they've added some some
filtering functions and things like this
and the the problem with that is because
it's not graph QL it means that that
doesn't work with any of the other graph
QL tools so you you can't just like wire
up Apollo clients to it because it's
it's not graph QL so things will break
there's actually I won't bring it up
here but there's a really good github
issue or some of the Apollo folks
basically said hey you say this is graph
QL but it doesn't work with any of our
tooling what's going on so so anyway so
that's that's one thing I think is a bit
confusing about D graph is it's not
actually not actually graph QL that you
know is compliant with the spec that
works with other graphic UL tooling in
the ecosystem but having said that the
with what they've done with the the
graph care language is really
interesting because they've taken taking
an interesting query language and sort
of added missing functionality I just
don't think they've done it in a way
that plays well with other tooling so so
anyway the answer to to your question is
sort of for if I want to build a graph
QL app with with an ear for J or or D
graph you know an important
consideration is how does it work
with other other tooling in the
ecosystem and so the these cypher schema
directives these are sort of the the
built-in way in the graph QL spec to
sort of extend graph QL so this means
that we're sort of extending graph QL by
annotating these fields but we're doing
in a way that is compliant with the spec
and that means it'll work with all of
the other
you all tooling in the ecosystem well
thank you
there's no more questions
[Applause]